maximum je donne tout de suite la parole
à jean-marc jancovici qui se
présentaient qui nous dit en cinq
minutes
ce qu'il faut savoir de son point de vue
sur cette question quels outils quelles
outils pour quels objectifs
alors le haut conseil pour le climat est
un ensemble de treize personnes qui sont
en cdd
np alors cdd donc on est en contrat à
durée déterminée on est nommé pour un
mandat de cinq ans et cnp parce que
c'est non payés voilà alors c'est quoi
plus sérieusement cette affaire-là
c'est un organe un de plus direz-vous
qui a été créée en novembre dernier
placé auprès du premier ministre et qui
est chargé alors on a un mandat qui est
extrêmement vague de donner un avis sur
la trajectoire française en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
en gros on dit ce qu'on veut sur la
politique climat de la france
bon alors c'est en gros c'est exactement
ça notre mandat la limite de l'exercice
qui est le qui est le nôtre en fait est
une limite de moyens et de temps parce
que comme je le disais quand on est 13
on ne sait toujours pas qui de judas
donc quand on est 13
en fait on est descendu à 11 pour le
moment on va remonter à xiii et qu'on a
un jour par mois de présence de réunions
plus un jour par mois de lecture de
documents échanges de mails etc
c'est assez facile de comprendre qu' il
ya des choses qu'on peut faire et des
choses qu'on peut moins facilement faire
et donc en pratique on regarde surtout
des grandes orientations et des grandes
tendances
on va dire il ya une partie facile à une
partie plus difficile dans notre travail
la partie facile c'est voir qu'on n'est
pas dans les clous donc là c'est très
facile faut 15 secondes pour voir qu'on
n'est pas dans les clous
la partie beaucoup plus difficile c'est
est ce qu'on peut avoir un avis sur
lequel on est tous d'accord parce qu'une
des limites ou un des mandats plus
exactement qu'on s'est fixés c'est que
on écrivait que des choses sur
lesquelles on était tous d'accord parce
que sinon on n'était pas capable d'aller
défendre ailleurs il ya une limite
importante
là c'est donc de rentrer un tout petit
peu dans le dans le détail des choses on
a sorti un premier rapport en juin
dernier
alors dans ce rapport en gros il ya
trois mois important il ya un mot qui
s'appelle cohérence
il ya un mot qui s'appelle planification
et ya un mot qui s'appelle justice alors
je vais revenir sur ces trois mots très
rapidement le mot cohérence il est
essentiel parce que en fait le défis que
nous pose le changement climatique
c'est le défi de confronter nos rêves de
grandeur et d'infini à la limite
physique de ce monde
voilà c'est ça le problème du changement
climatique c'est qu'on avait des rêves
de grandeur et d'infini vous vous avez
tous entendu les discours sur la
croissance économique qui est censé
durer 2
perpétuel et c'est qu'on a tous des
rêves d'infini qu' on peut exercer
chacun une liberté croissante sans gêner
celle d'à côté ça ça marche bien dans un
monde en croissance ça marche pas dans
un monde sans croissance
donc on est à devoir confronter la
vision qu'on avait avant d'une espèce
d'expansion sans limite à la difficile
limites physiques du monde et notamment
la limite physique sur le système
climatique qui est qu' il ya une
certaine quantité de co2 qu'on peut
mettre dans l'atmosphère avant de
trouver l'expérience extrêmement
désagréable voilà c'est ça le c'est ça
la première chose est alors donc cette
ce nous tous cette nouvelle limite qu'on
a dans la façon de gérer nos petites
affaires devient contradictoire avec un
certain nombre d'autres directions qu'on
avait prises et aujourd'hui on a un
problème de mise en cohérence et cette
mise en cohérence en fait ne se fera pas
sans choix c'est-à-dire sans abandon
c'est le poète a dit choisir c'est
renoncer
donc il ya des choses auxquelles on va
devoir renoncer malheureusement c'est ça
la mise en cohérence est aujourd'hui une
des fortunes des recommandations fortes
de notre rapport c'est que on ne se
donne pas la peine de faire cette mise
en cohérence c'est à dire qu'on ne se
donne pas la peine de se demander à nous
mêmes au fond qu'est-ce qu'on préfère si
on peut pas tout avoir
c'est sale c'est ça le premier
enseignement de notre rapport
le deuxième enseignement s'appelle
planification parce que la raison pour
laquelle on a aujourd'hui une société
qui est basée sur ce qu'on appelle les
énergies fossiles c'est à dire le
charbon le pétrole et le gaz
même en france vous savez que même en
france l'essentiel de l'énergie qui
alimente nos machines
c'est des énergies fossiles 1 c'est pas
essentiellement de l'électricité c'est
essentiellement des énergies fossiles à
commencer par le carburant des voitures
que vous utilisez tous et des avions que
nos amis de la guyane ont sûrement pris
pour venir ici à moins qu'ils joignent
en kayak de mer
donc ce que vous avez aujourd'hui qui
fait fonctionner le monde sait les
énergies fossiles et donc se passer de
ces énergies fossiles c'est changer la
façon dont le monde est organisé et
changer les villes changer les modes de
transport changer les modes alimentaires
etc qui sont des votes culturel a en
france on adore bien manger pour bien
raison etc
c'est des choses qui sont très longues
ce très long et donc sa demande de la
planification exactement comme dans les
choses importantes de notre ville qui
sont longues
par exemple élever un enfant en général
on planifie pas mais on essaye de faire
les choses avec constance et avec
organisation est en fait la
planification c'est ça donc l'aide le
deuxième enseignement fort de notre
rapport c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on se donne pas les moyens d'avoir une
action qui est organisée de façon un peu
cohérente dans le temps et puis le
troisième mot c'est justice parce qu il
est bien évident qu'il ya un moyen très
simple par exemple de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
trois quarts s'est tué les trois quarts
des gens physiquement ça marche très
très bien
on peut pas considérer que ce soit une
solution très juste voilà donc le la
question de savoir qu'est ce qu'on peut
proposer qui sera considéré comme
sympathique c'est ça à fond la justice
ans est acceptable
et bien c'est le troisième enseignement
important du rapport ce il faut
réfléchir à des mesures qui suscitent
quand même un minimum d'adhésion
ça veut dire en particulier un truc très
important c'est qu'elle doit être
comprise parce que c'est très compliqué
d'adhérer à un truc qu'on comprend pas
donc là il ya aussi un vrai sujet que
j'ai relevé dans les changes qui vient
de se presser des 2 me précédée là qui
est que ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement donc quand on a des idées
assez claires sur ce qu'on a envie de
faire en général on est capable de
l'exprimer de manière assez simple et
c'est préférable si on veut susciter
l'adhésion
voilà c'est ça les trois les trois
enseignements principaux de notre apport
c'est des éléments de gestion beaucoup
plus que des mesures précises
on n'a pas dit tiens il faudra limiter
la vitesse à 105,2 sur les autoroutes
merci beaucoup
jean marc jancovici
[Applaudissements]